hey guys I'm GameSpot managing editor
Justin hey wold everyone else is playing
super mario odyssey you're watching
stranger things doing something a lot
more fun so for today's biggest news
stories in the world of gaming you're
stuck with me
sorry so Microsoft finally has an answer
to all my emails and DMS asking when are
we gonna hear more about the Kinect and
when do I get to play a new Dance
Central game the answer is the Kinect is
dead ahead of its earnings report later
this week Microsoft revealed that it's
put an end to manufacturing of the
device meaning that those still sitting
on store shelves will be the last ones
available for purchase support for the
device will continue so there's no need
at least for now to worry if you're
someone who still enjoys playing the odd
game that uses it or pausing Netflix
with a voice command connects non gaming
applications have proven to be arguably
more useful even providing medical uses
and while the device itself may now
effectively be dead the technology
behind it will live on as aspects of it
are now used to power microsoft's
hololens augmented reality device Sega
has two sonic games this year one the
nostalgic love letter to fans sonic
mania is out now and sonic forces is
coming soon you get to try it now if you
want to but there's a pretty big catch
first the demo is currently only
available in the Japanese eat shop so
you'll need to have a Japanese Nintendo
account in order to access and download
it it's pretty easy to work around that
restriction but the other caveat is a
much weirder one there are only three
stages available in the demo and each
one has a one minute time limit you
probably won't be able to make much
progress in the demo version but at
least you won't have to wait much longer
to play the full thing Sonic forces
launches on November 7th for ps4 Xbox
one and PC Blizzcon is on the horizon
and while Blizzard has made it clear
that there's not gonna be a diablo 4
announcement and diablo 2 remastered is
probably not gonna be talked about at
least there's a new diablo 3 patch
version 2 point 6 point 1 which is out
now on PC ps4 and Xbox one doesn't
introduce any new features but it does
change Diablo 3 items and skills some of
which have seen runes completely
redesigned at a high level
Blizzard said that some skills have been
buffed while
have received adjustments for improved
playability and performance multiple
legendary items have also been buffed
while Blizzard has taken a close look at
how each class performs in greater Ritz
it said it's made several changes to
bring as many gameplay styles as close
in line to each other as possible with a
focus on the most popular or requested
builds in addition the game's newest
class necromancer sees more changes than
any other class and many of the habló
threes legendary and set items are now
more likely to drop and that's
Thursday's biggest news but you're
probably a little bit more excited for
Super Mario odyssey's review which you
can read and watch now as well as the
Assassin's Creed review and we're gonna
have Wolfenstein on the way soon ain't
Friday is gonna be a crazy day for new
games releases and you might want to
call in sick if you were someone who was
thinking about calling in sick if you
could let us know in the comments below
what excuse you're using I'm asking for
a friend
when are we gonna get in more Connect
new games on the way revealed that it it
is putting a little which is coming
really soon cards at least there's gonna
be a Diablo 3 announcement oh that was
wrong fans sonic mania is already out
and what was I saying I slide into their
deals